c'est la dernière ligne droite pour
cyril picard les dernières foulées de sa
préparation avant le dimanche 17 octobre
jour du marathon de paris 2021 pour cet
athlète de 43 ans spécialisé dans le
marathon depuis 2015 c'est un retour à
la compétition après la crise sanitaire
ça nous laisse beaucoup de doutes à nous
qui prépareront le marathon en fait
c'est jamais évident parce que les
sensations peuvent être bonne mais la
blessure peut arriver à tout moment donc
jusqu'au jour j il n'y a pas de
certitudes pour se préparer c'est pas
sorcier cinq séances par semaine le
mardi et le jeudi ça se passe au club
deux séances de fractionné
le mercredi c'est un footing de
récupération avant de conclure la
semaine par deux grandes sorties le
samedi et le dimanche une semaine type c
environ 80 kilomètres sur sept repas
marathons les plus grosses semaines je
suis monté à 100 km c'est dernière
participation remonte à 2019 avec le
marathon des alpes-maritimes et le
marathon de paris des performances en
dessous de 3 heures mon objectif pour ce
marathon de paris ça va être de réaliser
à nouveau
moins de trois heures
mais trois derniers marathons je les ai
réalisées en 2h59 j'aimerais bien
franchir à nouveau ce palier la vitesse
le jour j pour le marathon on va essayer
de tourner aux alentours de quatre
minutes entre 4 minutes 12 et 4 minutes
15 ooo km ce temps là lui permettra de
se qualifier aux championnats de france
de la catégorie master ram et une autre
ambition est déjà dans son esprit
décrocher une place dans le marathon des
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024